when you guys see someone who's on the
phone do you go up to them and ask them
hey are you on the phone
no
you don't
so the other day i was vlogging like i
do pretty much every single day and some
guy just stops in the middle of my
vlogging and asks if i'm face timing
what's that
no
i mean i'm posting this video but
not
crazy to me is this isn't the first time
that this has happened this happens all
the time now first of all i can see them
being a little bit confused about
vlogging but now facetiming you know if
someone is facetiming they are talking
to someone on the other end of that
conversation
excuse me
excuse me are you are you talking on
that are you talking on the telephone
are you speaking
if you're smart enough to know that
someone is facetiming then you're
probably smart enough to know that
you're interrupting a conversation
that's crazy it's just absolutely crazy
are people just rude or do they not
understand that that's live live video
now vlogging on the other hand may be a
little bit different and since i do this
daily i run into these people all the
time
oh yeah
um
i don't know and it's always so awkward
because i don't really know how to
recover from these awkward interactions
guys this is really awkward because this
guy is totally he totally knows i'm
talking to myself but um
yeah and you can hear everything i'm
saying so i'm gonna stop filming now for
me and for a lot of you guys you feel
like vlogging has been just going on
forever but to random strangers
it's so new and strange that i don't
think they actually have any concept
of what we're doing now the only time
that i absolutely love to get
interrupted while i'm vlogging is when i
meet one of you guys
yeah can i take a picture sure so now's
the question for you guys what are your
thoughts on vlogging are you a vlogger
do you watch people to vlog where do you
think vlogging is gonna go in the future
let me know what you guys think in the
comments below and maybe one of your
comments will get featured on one of my
second channel videos where i plan on
reading all of your comments and
responding and maybe not reading all of
them because you guys leave a lot of
comments but definitely some of them
i'll see you guys in my next video bye
hey thanks for making it at the end of
the video you are awesome be sure to
check out the last video that i posted
and my second channel so you guys can
see when i post that new little show
where i read all of your comments and of
course my daily vlogs on my iphone
channel uh okay bye